la tan esperada contraofensiva ucraniana
contra los rusos se ha hecho esperar los
medios de comunicación han estado meses
hablando de una campaña que no terminaba
de ponerse en marcha Durante los últimos
meses hemos visto pequeñas operaciones
ataques a depósitos de combustibles y
municiones rusos algún que otro susto en
crimea e incluso incursiones en
territorio ruso por ejemplo en el oblast
de velgorot Y por supuesto La tremenda
resistencia de Ucrania en bahamut pero
nada de ninguna contraofensiva a gran
escala a comienzos de junio de 2023 las
armas pesadas occidentales como los
tanques leopard o Los bradleys
Americanos todavía no habían entrado en
batalla sin embargo ahora ya está aquí
la acción ucraniana parece a punto de
caramelo si es que no ha comenzado ya y
por eso en visualpolitik nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas
que se ha [__] tanto la
contraofensiva ucraniana con Qué medios
exactamente cuentan los ucranianos para
llevarla a cabo Cómo están mejorando las
capacidades del ejército ucraniano
realmente tiene razón el secretario de
estado Anthony blinken cuando hace esta
afirmación
y quizás la pregunta más importante de
todas qué podemos esperar del Gran
contragolpe ucraniano Pues bien en este
vídeo os vamos a responder a estas y
otras preguntas preparad motores porque
arrancamos y sabéis que los ucranianos
también están arrancando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Las bajas la desesperación el
sufrimiento la destrucción la guerra se
está alargando Y hoy por hoy no tiene un
final visible El problema es que cada
vez será más y más difícil mantener el
esfuerzo de guerra por este motivo
Ucrania lleva meses preparando una
contraofensiva que en el mejor de los
casos puede suponer el fin de todas las
aspiraciones expansionistas del kremlin
en Ucrania y en el peor forzar unas
negociaciones de paz es uno de los
cuatro escenarios que os pintamos en un
pasado vídeo sobre el fin de la guerra
en Ucrania ahora bien esa contraofensiva
se ha demorado mucho más de lo esperado
y la pregunta es por qué Pues bien estos
son los principales motivos
por un lado tenemos el que quizás es el
factor menos determinante pero que no
Por ello deja de resultar clave el
tiempo este 2023 el clima ha hecho que
el suelo ucraniano haya tardado más
tiempo en descongelarse tras el invierno
lo que significa que el barro tan
característico De esta zona se ha
prolongado más de lo esperado en el
calendario y claro el suelo embarrado
puede dificultar seriamente el
movimiento de los vehículos militares
algo que juega en contra de ambos bandos
pero especialmente de quien lleva la
iniciativa Asimismo también se ha
producido un cierto retraso en lo que
respecta al entrenamiento de los
soldados y es que veréis en los últimos
meses de escenas de miles de soldados
ucranianos han sido entrenados por los
ejércitos de la otan un entrenamiento
por ejemplo para lograr que las tropas
ucranianas sean capaces de utilizar
eficazmente los vehículos de combate
blindados striker y Bradley los buses
autopropulsados paladín o los tanques
leopar y Challenger entre otros muchos
equipos Aunque sobre esta cuestión sobre
las armas hablaremos más adelante El
caso es que toda esta formación ha sido
algo más lenta de lo esperado
[Música]
Claro que eso no es todo otro factor que
explica el retraso en la contraofensiva
es la propia llegada de las armas
occidentales de hecho puede que este sea
el motivo de mayor peso
[Música]
buena parte de los equipos militares
comprometidos por los aliados en 2023
todavía no han llegado a Ucrania o lo
están haciendo con retraso por ejemplo
de los cerca de 300 tanques que estaban
comprometidos entre los que se incluyen
los leopardos A mediados de mayo sólo se
habían entregado unos 100 y de los
aproximadamente 700 vehículos de combate
como los Bradley solo habían llegado
unos 300 y claro lógicamente no podía
producirse la contraofensiva si las
armas todavía estaban en camino
y no se trata solo de las armas la
entrega de municiones también ha ido más
lenta de lo previsto aquí Tenemos que
tener en cuenta que Ucrania está
disparando según ha desvelado Una
parlamentaria ucraniana entre 6.000 y
8000 rondas cada día esto significa que
para llevar a cabo una contraofensiva en
la que Seguro seguro se va a multiplicar
el uso de las municiones los ucranianos
antes tienen que acumular suficientes
cerca del campo de batalla para no
correr el riesgo de quedarse secos
y ojo porque a todos estos retrasos
tenemos que sumarle otro problema el
enorme reto de la logística
Y es que a ver en cualquier guerra la
logística es una de esas cosas que no se
suelen tener en cuenta pero que a la
hora de la verdad pueden determinar la
victoria o La derrota Pero por qué está
siendo un problema pues porque aunque
las entregas internacionales le han
permitido a Ucrania tener un ejército de
tierra enorme y razonablemente bien
equipado al mismo tiempo también lo han
convertido en un ejército tremendamente
caótico con un sinfín de equipos
diferentes desde el punto de vista
logístico preparar para el combate a un
ejército formado sobre la marcha y
apaches entre decenas de países
diferentes implica tener que ser capaces
de equipar y reparar a la par un
leopardos un t-72 o un Bradley Y eso
podéis creernos es algo que no resulta
nada fácil todo se complica y mucho
desde la munición a las piezas pasando
por Los mecánicos el transporte o la
gestión de los equipos que hay que
enviar a reparar al exterior El problema
es que este operativo que tienes que
tener muy bien montado si quieres que la
contraofensiva tenga éxito y eso eso
queridos amigos lleva tiempo el enfoque
actual por el cual cada país dona una
batería de armas de manera fragmentadas
Está convirtiendo rápidamente en una
pesadilla logística para las fuerzas
ucranianas ya que cada batería requiere
un tipo específico de entrenamiento
mantenimiento y logística muchas de las
armas occidentales de Ucrania esperan
reparaciones lejos del frente las piezas
de artillería deben llevarse a cientos
de kilómetros del campo de batalla para
ser reparadas en territorio de la otan
ahora bien a pesar del retraso que se ha
producido en la tan ansiada
contraofensiva ucraniana lo que seguro
muchos os estaréis preguntando es cómo
puede desarrollarse esta operación
militar Con qué cuentan ahora mismo los
ucranianos para llevarla a cabo cuáles
son sus ventajas y cuáles son sus puntos
débiles Pues bien ya somos adelantado
algunos detalles pero ahora ahora vamos
a verlo todo con más profundidad atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pilla pilla ucraniano
la gran contraofensiva ucraniana parece
estar a punto de caramelo durante el mes
de mayo pudimos ver Quizás El
prolegómeno con acciones como estas 23
de mayo de 2023 la lucha en la región
fronteriza rusa tras la incursión entra
en el segundo día 31 de mayo de 2023 la
Guerra de Ucrania llega a Moscú
controles atacando ambas capitales
desarrolladas directa o indirectamente
con su apoyo el objetivo de todas estas
operaciones es doble por un lado
contribuyen a erosionar la moral de los
rusos y el propio liderazgo de Putin
ante los suyos Incluso en la televisión
Estatal rusa en el programa de la
propagantista olgas kaviva se ha
criticado al gobierno por la escasa
protección de las zonas fronterizas y
luego desde un punto de vista militar se
trata de obligar a los rusos a desviar
su atención y quizás desproteger algunas
zonas del frente en Ucrania los
ucranianos saben que a día de hoy Rusia
no tiene capacidad suficiente como para
blindar 1300 kilómetros de frente y
tendrá que elegir muy bien los sitios
donde crean que hay más riesgo de
acciones ucranianas y claro al final
esto les puede dar cierta ventaja a los
ucranianos el objetivo es hacer que la
otra parte crea cosas que no sucederán
Además los ucranianos han estado
preparando el terreno desde por lo menos
el comienzo de 2023 y no nos referimos
solo a la preparación de las tropas
fijaos
durante Prácticamente todo lo que
llevamos de 2023 los ucranianos han
estado atacando a diario instalaciones
logísticas de Rusia en zonas muy lejanas
del frente gracias a los jaimars a las
Bombas guiadas glsdb que tiene un
alcance de hasta 150 kilómetros y más
recientemente a los misiles Storm Shadow
entregados por el Reino Unido también se
han utilizado en algunos casos pequeños
drones suicidas con todo ello los
ucranianos han destruido numerosos
depósitos de combustible y municiones
puestos de Mando cuarteles y edificios
administrativos rusos algunos incluso
dentro del propio territorio de Rusia
ahora bien significa esto que ya está
todo listo basta con recibir las armas
comprometidas y atacar unos cuantos
objetivos clave Pues evidentemente no
hay otros muchos factores que tenemos
que tener en cuenta desde la logística
que ya hemos comentado hasta la
situación operativa de un ejército como
el ucraniano que ha sufrido un desgaste
Terrible y por eso el plan de acción
tiene que tener todas estas cuestiones
en cuenta atentos
[Música]
romper o continuar el frente
ya lo hemos contado en pasados vídeos
aquí en visualpolitik el ejército ruso
está en una situación terriblemente
inesperada para ellos las pérdidas en
número de hombres tanques blindados de
transporte e incluso helicópteros y
aviones están siendo muy importantes
mucho más de lo que jamás estimaron en
Moscú mientras tanto los ucranianos
están recibiendo grandes cantidades de
equipos militares Por ejemplo si en 2022
se enviaron viejos de 72 en 2023 ya
están llegando tanques occidentales y
junto a ellos también vehículos
blindados como los Bradley que tienen
potentes capacidades antitanque y ojo
quizás no estén llegando en gran número
pero hablamos de la entrega de armas que
ya no son restos de Arsenal sino armas
que usarían los propios ejércitos de
Estados Unidos o Reino Unido si entrasen
en una guerra hablamos de todo un enorme
catálogo de obuses autopropulsados
municiones de estándares otan misiles de
largo alcance aire Tierra como los
británicos Storm Shadow y hasta misiles
tierra aire sí Sparrow para derribar
misiles de crucero y cazas rusos y como
también todos sabéis ahora está sobre la
mesa incluso esta posibilidad los
aliados de Ucrania podrían entregar 50
f-16 eso exactamente Cuántos f-16
necesita Ucrania en este momento pero la
pregunta es exactamente cómo podrían
utilizarse todos estos equipos por
cierto sobre el f-16 publicaremos pronto
un vídeo específico aquí en
visualpolitik Así que no olvides
suscribirte al Canal si es que aún no lo
has hecho
a ver lógicamente Nuestro objetivo con
este vídeo no es adivinar los planes
concretos de la ofensiva Sin embargo a
juzgar por las armas que está recibiendo
Ucrania y por la situación actual del
frente sí que podemos hacernos una idea
de cómo podría desarrollarse esta acción
esto que vamos a ver a continuación Es
una posibilidad basada en las opiniones
de expertos militares e informes de
inteligencia amigos amigas los
ucranianos están recibiendo una enorme y
razonablemente moderna fuerza terrestre
con la que muchos analistas apuntan a
que es muy probable que la
contraofensiva ataque de lleno algún
punto altamente modificado por los rusos
con el objetivo de intentar romper el
frente en dos por ejemplo razonable
pensar que los ucranianos podrían usar
sus leopardos y sus vehículos de
transporte de tropas occidentales para
tratar de romper las defensas rusas en
zonas próximas a melipoll o incluso
Mario Paul en lugar de centrarse tanto
en el donbash como han hecho hasta ahora
y ese ataque podría comenzar por el
oblast de zaporilla de hecho los propios
rusos Están preocupados por esta
posibilidad fijaos 27 de abril de 2023
Rusia stringe era mientras Ucrania se
prepara para atacar las zanjas a titán
que cerca de la ciudad ocupada de Polo y
en el sureste de Ucrania se extienden a
lo largo de 30 km detrás hay filas de
barricadas de hormigón de dientes de
dragón más atrás se encuentran las
trincheras defensivas donde se
posicionarán las tropas rusas sí estamos
hablando de una línea de fortificaciones
que Rusia ha estado preparando Durante
los últimos meses especialmente en el
sur de Ucrania fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
toda esa línea de puntos que estáis
viendo en pantalla son fortificaciones
rusas que ya están identificadas digamos
que los rusos son conscientes de que su
mayor pesadilla puede ser precisamente
la ruptura del frente en la zona de
melipoll verdians o mariopol y por eso
han hecho todo lo posible para llenar
este espacio de obstáculos Minas y
trincheras Incluyendo los famosos
dientes de dragón seguro que los que
hayáis jugado al Call of Duty sabéis
bien A qué nos referimos El caso es que
hablamos de estrategias habituales de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial que ahora sin
embargo están de vuelta Aunque lo cierto
es que los dientes de dragón también
pueden verse actualmente en Corea del
Sur a lo largo de su frontera con Corea
del Norte
algunos tanques más modernos grandes y
potentes pueden atravesar los dientes de
dragón pero normalmente En estos casos
se usan equipos de ingenieros militares
como avanzadilla una vez que el terreno
se asegura con artillería estos equipos
se encargan de tareas tan importantes
como la limpieza de los campos de minas
la apertura de los caminos la
construcción de puentes y sí también la
destrucción de los dientes de dragón y
las trincheras y sus equipos son
fundamentales en cualquier ofensiva
militar Y por eso los ejércitos
occidentales más modernos les dan una
enorme importancia sin embargo en este
caso no está claro Hasta qué punto los
ucranianos tienen este tipo de cuerpos
con medios y preparación suficiente
[Música]
es decir todos estos obstáculos no serán
un impedimento para que los ucranianos
pasen pero sí un estorbo un retraso que
podía dejar a las tropas de zelensky
expuestas durante más tiempo del
recomendable en un terreno hostil nadie
dijo que le ha contraofensiva fuese a
ser fácil y de hecho esto explica por
qué la preparación ha llevado más tiempo
del estimado ahora bien Por qué a pesar
de todos estos inconvenientes muchos
analistas apuntan a que los ucranianos
pueden tener como objetivo principal
intentar romper las líneas rusas por
esta zona Pues bien básicamente por un
motivo crimea
Ucrania podría utilizar las armas
pesadas que ha recibido últimamente de
occidente para romper el frente ruso en
dos separando así criminal esto le
permitiría por un lado dificultar los
suministros rusos y por otro dejará
crimea mucho más expuesta además las
ganancias territoriales en el oublas de
zapolilla y de gerson permitirían a los
ucranianos tener a tiro con armas de
precisión menos escasas y caras el
puente de crimea que une la Península
con Rusia a través del estrecho de kerch
la destrucción de este puente y una
hipotética ruptura del frente ruso en
dos pondrían a crimia en una situación
de extrema vulnerabilidad y esto Esto es
algo que podría forzar a los rusos a
sentarse a negociar
unas negociaciones que podrían consistir
en La retirada total de Ucrania o una
parcial a excepción de la propia crimea
que podría ser reconocida como rusa en
última instancia ahora bien un momento
no nos engañemos
[Música]
si finalmente se llevan a cabo estos
planes durante la contraofensiva u otros
parecidos es muy posible que el coste en
vidas para los ucranianos pueda contarse
en miles y miles decenas de miles de
bajas La pregunta es Existe alguna forma
de evitar una nueva sangría nuevos a lo
largo de un frente mucho más grande Pues
bien Lo cierto es que sí una de las
formas podría ser entregando a gift el
tan ansiado sistema de misiles tácticos
del ejército de Estados Unidos unos
misiles que pueden atacar con precisión
objetivo situados a una distancia de
hasta 300 Kilómetros Sin embargo en
Washington no aparecen dispuestos al
menos por ahora a poner en manos
ucranianas este sistema y la pregunta es
por qué Pues bien veámoslo
el último as bajo la manga
Estados Unidos ha sido con muchísima
diferencia el mayor donante de armas a
Ucrania hasta la fecha los
contribuyentes estadounidenses han
gastado desde que diera comienzo la
invasión cerca de 40.000 millones de
dólares en asistencia militar a Ucrania
para que os hagáis una idea hablamos de
unos 3 millones y medio de dólares cada
hora una gigantesca cantidad de recursos
que ha nutrido el enorme catálogo de
armas entregadas del que ya os hemos
hablado largo y tendido tanto aquí en
visualpolitik como en nuestro boletín de
patrón las claves de la semana por
cierto Recuerda que si te unes a nuestra
comunidad de patreon podrás estar a la
última con este boletín recibir otras
recompensas y además ayudarnos a seguir
mejorando os dejamos toda la info en la
descripción Pues bien El caso es que
pese a todo hay un arma que sigue
resistiéndose el sistema de misiles
tácticos del ejército de Estados Unidos
Washington al menos por ahora no quiere
ni oír hablar de entregar estos misiles
a pesar de que los ucranianos llevan ya
un año pidiéndolos ahora bien porque son
tan reticentes a entregar este arma
Pues bien simple y llanamente para
evitar escalar todavía más el conflicto
Esa es la principal explicación pero
como demonios podrían estos misiles
escalar aún más un conflicto en el que
ya hemos visto hasta incursiones
terrestres en el propio territorio ruso
Pues bien el pentágono cree que llegado
el caso Ucrania podría utilizar estos
misiles contra territorio ruso lo que
podría terminar provocando la tan temida
escalada nuclear en Washington no
quieren bajo ningún concepto arriesgarse
a esa posibilidad hasta ahora han
frenado cualquier tentación de Moscú al
respecto pero claro un ataque directo a
Rusia podría cambiarlo todo el riesgo
desde luego existe Y sí ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos de los que
estáis más puestos en el tema pero
Alberto si Ucrania Ya tiene los misiles
Storm shado británicos que alcanzan
objetivos a más de 250 kilómetros Pues
sí es verdad tiene razón
la diferencia es que los misiles
tácticos norteamericanos pueden ser
lanzados desde lanzadores portátiles
fáciles de esconder en cualquier
recoveco mientras que los estorbs ADO
uso mucho más engorrosos y arriesgados
de usar porque solo se pueden lanzar de
aviones que hoy por hoy tiene una
capacidad muy limitada y un radar poco
avanzado los misiles estadounidenses En
cambio no tendrían esos problemas lo que
le permitiría a los ucranianos golpear
sin riesgos la mayor parte de los
puestos de Mando rusos y los depósitos
de armas y no solo eso también incluso
las defensas en el istmo de crimea o el
propio puente que separa esta región de
Rusia en el estrecho de kerch
[Música]
hablamos de unos misiles que además
serían difíciles de interceptar ya que
viajan a tres veces la velocidad del
sonido con lo que podrían convertirse en
toda una pesadilla para los rusos por
eso la rotunda negativa de Washington a
entregar estos misiles genera preguntas
sobre si Estados Unidos podría no querer
realmente una victoria decisiva de
Ucrania una que fuese una humillación
militar para ru sea como sea lo que está
claro es que estamos a punto de vivir
uno de los momentos más críticos de esta
guerra Pero mientras eso sucede el turno
es para ti crees que los ucranianos
conseguirán romper en dos el frente ruso
será crimea un objetivo real y
prioritario o por el contrario no es más
que una distracción terminará entregando
Estados Unidos su sistema de misiles de
largo alcance déjanos tus opiniones aquí
debajo en los comentarios y muy
importante si te ha gustado este vídeo
No te olvides de darle al botón de like
suscribirte a nuestro canal si es que
aún no lo has hecho y darle a la
campanita Para no perderte ninguna
novedad Y recuerda si quieres acceder a
contenidos exclusivos puedes suscribirte
a nuestro patreon os dejamos también el
enlace abajo en la descripción una vez
más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]